You my friend,
the first thing you said to me when I sat down was,
oh my God,
you look like somebody I arrested before.
Dude,
I've known you for like two minutes.
I don't even know your name
currently or previously have worked in law enforcement against that wall on that
side.
I am nervous about what is going to happen today.
Okay.
Uh,
apparently people are a lot braver than I am.
So,
you know,
are there a lot more comfortable with their stories?
So
I'm just more excited to be here and,
uh,
to share my stories,
to hear everybody else's story for me more.
So it's,
uh,
you know,
in our situations like you're kind of conditioned,
like,
you guys are the enemy,
you know,
I don't know how you guys feel about us or,
I've never had a deeper conversation with law enforcement.
Probably from your point of view is,
is that it doesn't always seem like the justice system is fair.
Uh,
I think that what you find though,
if it's a few truly love this job and this work that you strive to find that
balance and fairness.
I,
I'm,
I'm puzzled by what he's saying because I've never heard anything like this
before because I mean,
if it's true,
what you're saying then,
how come police aren't policing police?
Why are you standing idly by while your fellow officers are going around
shooting and killing unarmed black people?
Why is that happening?
Yeah.
Aye.
I sold drugs.
That's why I did,
I sold a shit ton of drugs and,
um,
I didn't have family.
I never had,
you know,
I mean,
I grew up in foster homes.
I didn't have any type of family,
but I fucking knew that when I went to prison,
I knew I didn't want to come back to this shit.
You know what I'm saying?
So while I was in prison,
I knew I needed to start there and build a foundation.
I've been out of trouble since 1999,
you know,
so I chose to Kevin my own crimes when I was younger.
I wanted it,
the violence.
I could have easily chose to do something else,
but I was always there when things were going to happen.
I was talking about thinking about between my professional life or my personal
life,
anything illegal man,
we're playing some nights.
I think that like,
you know,
it's,
it's one of those things where like you look at,
for instance,
have I have I killed anybody have robbed anybody,
have I like all these major felonies now I have,
I have,
I sped before.
Yeah,
absolutely.
You know what I hear is you're telling me there's levels of legality.
I mean,
I used to be sort of on that end too.
Like I grew up,
well,
I went to private schools.
I mean,
I'm not somebody,
you know,
like with stereotype as somebody who gone to prison,
and then I've gone to prison and I just find out how fucked up the system is.
I mean,
what about the guy who goes out,
has dinner and has a drink,
ends up set spending seven or eight years in prison because somebody started a
fight with them.
But then I meet people in prison who've shot somebody in the back of the head
execution style and only got 10 years for it,
you know?
Whereas for me,
I spent 13 years in prison because somebody was hurting my family and I thought
like,
okay,
well we're going to go get our stuff back from this person and I get conspiracy
to commit robbery,
conspiracy,
you know,
use a gun,
which has added another 10 years and it's nothing ever happened.
You know,
nobody got hurt and like maybe it's cultural,
maybe it's,
you know,
I grew up where like you defend your family,
and yeah,
like was it a bad,
a sec.
Sure.
Can I ask a question though?
Like why your first thought wasn't like,
let me call the cops to help solve this issue because you know what?
Like from my experience growing up,
cops don't help.
They just come by,
show up and make a great show of doing their jobs and then leave.
But I'm just saying there's no consistency in the system.
It makes no sense.
It depends on which county you go to,
which judge you show up in front of.
It's a political game.
It's,
that's not justice.
What would you consider justice to be?
I mean I would like to see that there would be some consistency if I go to La
county or San Diego or wherever,
that the same crimes would carry the same time.
There would be some consideration for you know,
situation.
I don't think there is
justice.
The criminal justice system truly does help to protect societies.
If we did not have it,
that there would be chaos.
Well,
um,
it may not be perfect right now,
but we need the justice system and we have to believe it
for some reason.
It just seems to me that if you are from a low through a family,
you're easy to get off the hook.
When I was fighting my case,
I had a celly who was fighting the same crime that I committed for an attempted
murder.
He had came back.
I said that the judge gave him one year with two strikes.
I don't know how that went about,
but for me I ended up getting 10 years with one strike and his family was
wealthy in that.
Did you have priors?
Did he have priors?
I,
I had no priors.
I just didn't understand why.
Is it that,
you know,
if your family has more money,
it's easier to get off the hook.
A lot of times I saw that if you have a private attorney,
high power attorney,
I guess you have a better chance of getting off than having public defender.
That could be a little,
a little hole in the criminal justice system,
but that's how it is right now.
And then I don't know how to address that issue.
So I guess that's,
it shouldn't be a game.
It shouldn't be a game with people's lives.
Like how,
how can I get this when?
How can I negotiate a win with this person's life?
At the end of the day,
man,
it's all about money and it's about numbers and there was no visit this,
there's no money in rehabilitation,
man.
There's money in recidivism.
Tell some money,
and I could give up my job today as a result of no other people going to jail,
which means that they would actually stop committing crimes.
I would do it in a heartbeat,
but there's not too many people like you.
If we had a system,
all them guys like you that awesome.
I think that that's again,
see what you just said is that's the perception that you have is it though it's
a reality for us,
for me,
when I was inside and the nonprofit that I work for,
we had,
you know,
the programs in there and this is a class that ar is going to help them,
actually do something with their lives every evening while the guys are going to
class.
Like they get harassed and then we come out of the class and all the cops are
lined up and like get on the wall,
strip search,
tear up textbooks,
tear up their personal property there,
their homework.
Like,
yeah,
that's how the system is.
Like on the way out of prison,
officers were telling me like,
I'll see you back on the next one.
You know,
like,
that's fucking bullshit.
Yeah.
Out of everybody in the circle.
Um,
that he was the first one to actually voice,
uh,
the fact that he made choices.
It's in that moment that the claim dominion over themselves.
So I appreciate that.
Thank you.
I don't know how they feel about that.
Um,
I don't think any one of us right here sat here and say like,
I didn't make my own choices.
I understand.
I made my own choice.
I got myself my own time.
I think I get the sense that you can do to,
without a doubt.
I think the larger issue is that the system is broken and I,
that's what I have a problem with.
I don't have a problem with taking ownership of my actions.
It's society not taking ownership of its own creation.
You don't hear that he was the one,
he was the only person that vocal in saying that.
I will ask you this.
So then I'll challenge you.
Do you know who your representative is to?
Have you ever contacted their office?
No.
Have you ever contacted your Congress member?
Then I suggest that you should.
I mean,
and here's the thing,
because you strike me as a very smart individual that has the ability to go in
influence.
I agree with you as,
I just think that you need to take a walk in our shoes.
You know,
like,
and I don't mean any disrespect by this,
but you sound like an uh,
law enforcement pamphlet.
You know,
like you sound like every perfect thing,
but they want you to say,
it's kind of like when you work in a company and the CEO says this is the
policy,
but when you're on the ground level,
you know that there are certain things that just doesn't work in reality.
I think you have,
you know,
great views and I think you're,
if we had,
you know,
law,
like just a team of law enforcement that is exactly like you to,
you know,
I have the same view.
It's like it would be great,
you know?
But I also think that there is reality when you come out of prison,
everything's just so stacked against you.
That's a commonality.
So like when a,
for instance,
when I talk about coming out of the military,
I had people that told me when and where to be,
all these rules and regulations.
And when I got out,
you know,
there was nobody there.
Same thing happens in prison.
You have to break out of the prison mind mentality.
Here's the difference between the mill.
And I agree with you,
there's a lot of similarities.
There are a lot of commonalities with prison in the military.
However,
when you're in the military,
you're told you're the men of this country are the defenders of this country,
your men,
then you'd go to prison.
We were told that were pieces of shit.
We were told that we're animals,
you know?
Um,
and when you've gone through a decade of that,
it,
it gets in your head,
inside your mind.
It's like,
who am I like,
who am I to think that I can do these things?
It just turns you into nothing,
you know,
and,
and makes you believe that you're nothing,
that she can't do it.
And that's something that you can't put into,
you know,
LAPD policy,
and that's what the justice system does to you.
Like it breaks you.
But you know what?
I can tell you this,
me looking at you,
I don't see any of the things that you,
that you talk about.
I would hope for you and for actually all three of you that you know that you
guys are able to,
to escape those,
those boundaries that had been created.
Because guess what,
at the end of the day,
like you have one life to live and it's going to be predicated upon the
decisions that you make now.
Okay.
I honestly believe that they have a structure in place that can help the people
who are running it are the ones that need adjusting.
I think it needs a lot of work.
I think the resources are put in to a lot of the wrong places and I'm not okay
with saying,
well this is what we got,
so let's try to work with it.
Like,
no,
I think that there should be moves to try to improve the system.
Like I don't think we should ever be consent,
you know?
Um,
like I say,
unfortunately when the budget crisis happens,
training is the first one that goes out the,
I think they need more training.
If they're training,
say of the one life,
I think it's the work thing.
Awesome.
Think a communication to build a unity in the community.
That way that it can be trusted with one another and be able to,
to work with one another with all the challenges that's going on in this chaotic
world.
No,
no worries
man.
Do you have any information on your nonprofit or actually,
let me give you look at them.
Perfect.
Good luck.
Hey guys,
much appreciation.
Uh,
we get to do what we love because y'all all watch our videos,
so if you really love us,
you'll continue to keep watching videos.
There's more right here that you can check out.
You probably haven't seen all of them,
and if you really want to just commit to us,
you can subscribe right here.
I'll be around,
I'll be at the end of some more videos and I will keep in touch piece.